hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
we have the Avengers end game Prelude
number 2 now now much like the first
Avengers in game prelude comic that
we've got this doesn't really tell us
too much about Avengers end game it's
more of a recap of what happened during
the events of Avengers infinity war
there is a nice message from Stan Lee at
the end so be sure to stick around so
you can see that but this is essentially
Avengers infinity ward in a comic so I'm
going to go through it I'm going to show
each page because I know some people
can't get comics there's a few things
that are a little bit different and a
few things that get a little bit of
clarification to them so I'll talk about
them and I'll go through it like I said
but for the most part this is a recap of
the middle part of Avengers infinity war
the first prelude that came out was a
recap of the first part this is going to
be the second part in the next prelude
will be the third part because there are
three prelude comics
so this prelude actually starts off with
a tribute to Stan Lee it shows a picture
of them and below it says Stanley 1922
to 2018 he will definitely be missed
very very much so the last Avengers
in-game prelude comic ended with the
Scarlet Witch and vision fighting Corvus
glaive and Proxima midnight right before
Captain America shows up so these second
Prelude starts off with Captain America
Falcon and Black Widow showing up they
defeat Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight but of course they get away
they all get on the Quinjet and Captain
America says to go home we then go to
the flashback scene where Thanos and
Gamora meet for the very first time
Thanos wipes out half of the population
of her planet her parents included and
then takes Gamora and raises her but in
this trip we actually get some more
clarification on just how Thanos would
wipe out half of these planets
populations when he went playing at the
planet evany ma is instructing the
people on the planet he says z ho
barians choose a side or die one side is
a revelation the other and honor known
only to a few so as we saw an infinity
war they have the people choose a side
one side lives the other side does and
the honor that evany MA is talking about
is death dying at the hands of Thanos
and the chill
thanos so if a knows when it personally
kill half of the population on each
planet he had an army and he had leaders
of the army his children of Fanus the
next scene we get is where quill
promises Gamora that if Thanos gets his
hands on her he'll kill her
they arrived at nowhere and of course
Thanos tricks everybody with the reality
stone Gamora tells quill to kill her and
the two of them say I love you to each
other but of course when quill fires
only bubbles come out and right before
dinos leaves with Gamora he says I like
him I've always thought that Diana says
this because star-lord actually had the
guts and a strong enough will to pull
the trigger because that's why fan O's
has set out to balance the universe he
thinks he's the only one with the strong
enough will to be able to do it so I
think he kind of respects quill for
being able to pull the trigger and
that's why he says I like him we then go
to New York and the Avengers compound
where rody is talking to Ross Ross calls
Captain America and his team criminals
and of course when Captain America shows
up he says I'm not looking for
forgiveness and I'm Way past asking for
permission earth just lost Tony Stark so
we're here to fight and if you want to
stand in our way
we'll fight you too Ross tells Rhodey to
arrest them and obviously Brody doesn't
Ben Bruce Banner shows up and The
Avengers have a little reunion vision
then says that they have to destroy the
stone and Wanda is the only person who
can destroy it because she got her
powers from the mine stone but Bruce
says that there may be a way to separate
vision from the mine stone and vision
still be okay so they had to akanda
because Bruce doesn't have the
technology at the current lab and
Wakanda black panther is preparing his
armies for battle and gives Bucky his
brand new vibranium arm we then go to
ebony moss ship that has Evan Emma dr.
strange Iron Man and spider-man aboard
it just like in the movie evany ma is
torturing dr. strange to try and get the
time stone from him spider-man pops out
and says hey Tony guess what I'm on the
ship and comes up with his alien plan
Tony Stark blast a hole in the side of
the ship sucking Eponine maw out into
space but Doctor Strange gets sucked out
too and spider-man goes after him and
the words in the comics are actually a
little bit different than the words in
the movie spider-man says got him whoa
but I didn't think this through the
vacuum is pulling me out too and that's
where we see his iron spider-man legs
for the very first time
Doctor Strange tells Tony to turn the
ship around but Tony says he doesn't
think they should he thinks they should
bring the fight to him strains agrees
but says if it comes down to saving Tony
or the kid or that time stone he won't
hesitate to let Tony or spider-man die
Tony says nice good moral compass and
then he nights Peter Parker and Avenger
we then go to Thanos his ship the
sanctuary to where him and Gamora are
talking in his throne room
Gamora explains that she hates the ship
and she always hated him and that she
kidnapped him from her planet Danis then
says I saved you your planet was dying
and on the brink of collapse people were
going to bed hungry every night but
since he balanced it it's now a paradise
this is where Thanos explains that the
universe is unbalanced it's running out
of resources and it needs correcting and
he's the only one that knows and can
correct it but of course he needs the
soul stone and he knows that Gamora
knows where it is we then go to the
scene where he's torturing nebula and
eventually Gamora ends up telling him
that the soul stone is on for Mary the
scene is always oddly nice because we
can see that after guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 nebula and Gamora actually
really care for each other now his
sisters and Gamora is willing to risk
Diana's getting the soul stone in order
to save her sister we then go to the pod
where Thor rocket and Groot are heading
to neduvaali R Thor is explaining
neduvaali R to Groot he says tree you'll
know when we're close net oval ears
Forge harnesses the blazing power of a
neutron star is the birthplace of my
hammer Thor explains that once he gets
his hammer he'll be able to defeat
Thanos fate wills it so they get to
Netivot lair and Thor automatically
knows that something is wrong because
the star is out and the forge has gone
dark in this strip we actually get a
pretty good shot at the mold for the
Infinity Gauntlet that each remade I've
heard that a lot of people actually
think that this was an actual Infinity
Gauntlet it was not it was a mole views
to make the real Infinity Gauntlet a
tree then comes out and explains that
Thanos came and demanded that each tree
make him the gauntlet and then he ended
up killing all of his people and he took
away a tree's hands Thor gives him a
little pep talk and says it's not your
hands that make you great but your mind
and together we can defeat Thanos Eitri
says I have a mold for a king's weapon
Stormbreaker meant to be the greatest
and asked
in theory it could even summon the
Bifrost I always found it interesting
that Eitri says it's meant to be the
greatest and Asgard this would mean that
Stormbreaker is stronger than Odin's
spear gun near now I'm not saying that
Thor is stronger than Odin I'm just
saying in theory Stormbreaker could be
stronger than gun near the next comic
strip shows nebula escaping she goes to
the computer right away she radios
mantis and says mantis listen very
carefully I need you to meet me on Titan
so this is how the guardians of the
galaxy knew to go to Titan because
nebula told them to there's actually a
deleted scene in Avengers infinity war
where the guardians of the galaxy are
floating around in space and mantis is
staring at this blinking light well the
blinking light is actually the call from
nebula and it shows the guardians of the
galaxy receiving nebulas message and
heading out to Titan the coded message
channel has just been on a blinking
yellow light indicates an important
secret coded message shailen how this is
your job so then the rest of the strip
shows dr. strange spider-man and Iron
Man arriving at Titan trying to land the
ship obviously they are not too good at
flying alien spaceships so Doctor
Strange helps him out by putting the
protective barrier around them while
they crash after they crashed Doctor
Strange helps Tony up and says that was
close I owe you one and this is where
spider-man's spidey senses were tingling
because he knew that somebody was about
to come into the ship and right when
Spiderman says I'm trying to say that
something is coming he gets hit with one
of star Lords concussive grenades and
this is where the guardians of the
galaxy rush onto the ship Jack starts it
off by yelling Thanos and then gets
attacked by dr. Strange's cloak
star-lord and Iron Man start fighting
and then Peter Parker runs into mantis
and he thinks she's an alien about to
put eggs inside of him of course we know
how this ends
spider-man webs up mantis then star-lord
grabs ahold of spider-man and then Iron
Man goes over and steps on Drax there
are actually some words here that aren't
said in the movie Iron Man says here
strange I'll handle him sit still Jolly
Green Giant now give us back the kid
star-lord then puts his gun to
spider-man's head and tells everybody to
chill out and of course we know how this
scene go
yeah I'll tell you one better who's
Gomorrah I'll do you one better
why is Gomorrah and that is actually the
last scene in the Avengers in game
Prelude number two so like I said it's
really just a recap of the middle part
of Avengers infinity ward there wasn't
any new information about Avengers in
game and this Prelude much like the
first one however it could be different
for the Avengers in game Prelude number
three Prelude number three will of
course wrap-up Avengers infinity war but
will probably have something that ties
the ending of infinity war to the
beginning of Avengers endgame they
usually do that for these prelude so
keep an eye out for Avengers in game
Prelude number three and of course like
I said there's a message from Stan Lee
that I want to end on it's from Stan's
soapbox and it says hang loose heroes
now that I've got your ear I'm not
letting go
our first Tintin ablating topic is gonna
be the Marvel philosophy whenever I get
together with any of you frantic ones
the first question posed is usually what
are you fellas really trying to do in
your max what message are you pushing is
the whole Marvel series just a big
put-on or are you trying to tell us
something are you actually serious about
your characters do you really believe in
of etc' well just between us we believe
in our coverton characters a lot more
than we believe in some people we know
that we do have a motive a purpose
behind our max the purpose is plain and
simple to entertain you we think we've
found the best formula of all we merely
create the type of fanciful yarns that
we ourselves enjoy and if we like them
you ought to like them too after all
you're our kind of people
now then in the process of providing
offbeat entertainment if we can also do
our bit to advance the cause of
intellectualism and MANET arianism and
mutual understanding and toss a little
swing and satire at you in the process
that won't break our collective heart
one tiny bit that's it pussycat thanks
for listening amazing words from an
amazing man who we all know and love and
who was responsible for all of the
characters that we know and love and he
will be dearly missed so that's it for
the avengers end game Prelude number 2
breakdown let me know your thoughts and
like I said be on the lookout for the
Avengers in game Prelude number 3
and also I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet if you would like to
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]